foreign
welcome to this new video by simply
learn search engine optimization has
been playing an essential role in the
success of various businesses for those
who are still looking for growth in the
industry and have search engine
optimization otherwise known as SEO as
their primary weapon then yes you are in
the right place this video on how to
rank number one on Google will give you
the best tips to get a higher ranking
without spending a penny but before we
begin subscribe to our Channel simply
learn and hit the Bell icon to never
miss any updates from Simply learn so
before we begin I have a question for
you the process of getting the quality
and quantity of traffic to your website
organically is known as search engine
marketing search engine optimization
search engine advertising or none of the
above let me know your answers in the
comments section Below in this video
first we will understand why it's
essential to rank high in search engines
next we will have a look at the top five
mantras on how to get ranked number one
on Google search result pages and while
understanding this we will put a light
on why these success tips are important
for getting a good ranking and how we
can actually implement it we will share
some necessary tools to help you carry
out the needed process and stick to the
end of this video to find out the one
thing that can impact your business
tenfold
so definitely we're going to take a look
at the best tips for ranking high on
Google but before that it is necessary
to understand why it's important to rank
high on Google
well we are all aware that most of the
businesses are shifting online nowadays
ranking on search engines has become one
of the most important aspects that
Define the success of a business
the data states that around 1.17 billion
people across the globe use Google
search which is estimated to increase
exponentially in the coming years
moreover Google has gained the trust of
their users with their services over the
years this definitely makes the point of
interest to understand why it's
important to rank high on Google search
ranking at the top of search engine
result pages also known as serps allows
a business to generate more traffic to
their website and possibly get more
leads by which then they can get a
chance to convert leads into customers
thereby boosting sales
it also helps in generating authenticity
for your business well not one or two
there are numerous reasons which makes
SEO important to know more about SEO
check the complete playlist on SEO you
can find the link to the playlist in the
description box below
to gain expertise in search engine
optimization get certified as a skilled
SEO professional with simply learns
search engine optimization training
course you can check the course details
from the link in the description box
below as we know how important it is to
rank high on Google so in the next 10
minutes let's get to know the top five
success mantras that will help you rank
high-end Google so the fifth tip on our
list is promote your content
whether you are a business owner or a
blogger you definitely need to promote
your content to get a good audience
reach buy content here we mean data on
your website that can be products
services or even a simple blog to do
this find the relevant groups on the
social media platforms like Facebook or
Instagram and post your content with an
excellent call to action context some
blogging or article submission sites
like quora Tumblr and hub pages may also
prove helpful online forums and
communities can be a good option to
spread a word about your content with
people having similar interests let's
focus on our number four tip internal
linking a good site architecture is
always a happy bite for web crawlers a
website with good site architecture and
internal linking helps web crawlers
understand the website structure and
helps them to crawl the site more
effectively the more the pages of your
website are crawled greater are the
chances of getting indexed if pages are
successful fully indexed they get
eligible for appearing in the search
results
let's move to our tip number three yes
it is backlink building any website
linking to your website is a backlink
for your website websites with more
backlinks suggest to the search engine
crawlers that that website has good
content and is trustworthy and should be
ranked higher on the search result pages
to get a backlink the most important
thing is to understand that the da or
the domain authority of the website for
which you are looking for the backlink
is greater than yours getting backlinks
is somewhat entirely a gesture of
Goodwill you can find a page relevant to
your business and ask the website owner
to add the link to your website to the
page in a humble manner you can create a
better or updated version of some other
web content let the site owner know
about it and then ask for a backlink in
a humble way yes you can find some more
relevant backlink building techniques in
the video how to build backlinks check
out the link in the description box
below and number two we have a tip which
is of utmost importance to win a good
position in the search results on page
optimization on-page optimization are
also known as on-page SEO is a process
in which we take essential measures to
improve the website or web pages
position in search engine rankings
on-page optimization is a vast concept
that includes technical optimization of
websites like server speed page loading
speed removing page errors submitting
Pages for indexing and more maintaining
a good website structure and improving
it adding internal and external links on
the site adding SEO optimized images and
video on the page efficient use of
keywords on the page and links and much
more
get the detail guide to learning on-page
optimization by simply learn
check the link in the description box
below and finally the best tip we have
is the most effective one and the one
that rules them all which is keyword
research
keyword research is a process of
identifying and implementing the
relevant keywords for the content you
tend to create
proper keyword research may prove a boon
to your business but it also has the
power to ruin your business so be wise
When selecting your keywords try
choosing long tail keywords if you are
new to the business as these are easier
to rank for you can look at Google's
Auto suggest feature to understand what
people are looking for in your industry
be updated with what your competitors
are doing if something is working for
your competitor there are high chances
that it may work for you as well you can
also take the help of various keyword
research tools like Google's own Keyword
Planner answer the public tool Google
Trends and Etc
these fantastic and 100 practical tips
can drive your business to Heights make
sure you implement all these tips with
more detailed attention as SEO can make
and break you so what according to you
is the most effective way to grow your
business online let us know in the
comments below
so here I would like to end this session
with a hearty promise to come back with
another interesting topic of SEO here's
a general reminder to subscribe to the
channel and hit the Bell icon to stay
tuned with the latest updates from
Simply learn keep watching and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here